[Music]
San Francisco barrier welcomes you huge
welcome you see the lobster I do yes I
said the lobster yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
lobsters everywhere I guess they just
made a lobster emoji that seems
synchronous right seems like a
synchronous event it's quite funny I
want the one where you're riding the
lobster yeah well you can buy those
posters if you're really into that sort
of thing
new fetishes yeah Oh Jordan where do we
even start
well you're the interviewer amazing
amazing work over the last year you for
me someone that you remind me of is Tony
Robbins
I think he's taller someone that knows
how to
inspire people to self-actualization and
I find that to be deeply needed in our
world and that's what you've been doing
and it's brilliant beautiful and I think
this is why you bring people together
like this so so something that you
brought to the attention of so many
people is the dominance or competence
hierarchy
Why What let's maybe talk about what's
what's the difference dominance or
competence hierarchy I kind of like
competence hierarchy yeah it's better
yeah yeah well I got this colleague his
name is Daniel Higgins and I've been
working with him for like 25 years he
helped me design the self authoring
suite which is a series of programs
writing programs that are online that
help people write about their lives
their past and their present there
virtues in their faults and to make a
plan for the future we've talked a lot
he he was a
master's degree at MIT in engineering
and then he went to Harvard he was a
student of mine there and he got a PhD
in experimental psychology
we've been working on these
psychological interventions online ever
since and we talk fairly frequently and
I'd been using the term dominance
hierarchy a lot which it's something
that's used by biologists very regularly
right because most social animals even
animals that aren't social any animals
that have to compete for occupation of a
specific territorial space tend to
organize themselves into fairly
predictable hierarchies and it's it's
it's a biological Universal that's a
good way of thinking about it which is
something really important to know right
because if you don't know that then you
might think that hierarchical
organizations are some secondary
consequence of a socio-political
structure or an economic structure or
something like that and it's just that's
just not true it isn't even a little bit
true it's unbelievably not true and well
this is partly why in ruel in twelve
rows for life I wrote about the nervous
system of crustaceans in rule number one
because the neurobiological systems that
we have evolved or that have evolved to
deal with dominance hierarchy placement
I'll get to the competence issue in a
minute or at least a third of a billion
years old and that's far longer than
theirs that's that's there weren't trees
a third of a billion years ago so
dominance hierarchies hierarchical
organizations among animals are older
than trees it's like there's no blame in
them on capitalism right this is it's
just well seriously the hierarchies have
problems that they're problematic social
structures but you can't blame them on
on on on on cultural you can't blame
them on culture anyways we're talking
about dominance hierarchies
dr. Higgins said you can't call them
dominance hierarchies I said why not I
said he said well unless you're in an
organization where you can put a dog
leash around someone's neck and lead
them around it's not a dominance
hierarchy and I thought he's kind of
blunt as you might have noticed by that
comment kind of shocked me a because
because it was so blunt there's lots of
that that happens in San Francisco yeah
well the thing is well you know that
that's actually an operable comment
because dominance is just as old as
sexuality perhaps perhaps not quite as
old it's not quite as old as sexuality
but it's old enough so that the two
things get tangled together very very
inevitably so he said he said two things
that I thought were really interesting
and the first was that human
organizations are sufficiently complex
so the dominance is an insufficient
means of establishing hierarchical
priority that's good and I thought
that's right I knew that as soon as he
said that I thought yeah I shouldn't be
using the term dominance herky because
Fran's de Waal who's a Dutch
primatologist wrote a series of
excellent books on the emergence of
morality and chimpanzees I would highly
recommend them they're very interesting
books one of the things de Waal noted
was that in chimpanzee hierarchies the
brutal males can rise to the top but
they tend to have very short-lived
empires and to meet very very violent
deaths and so his his conclusion was
that in order even for a chimpanzee
hierarchy to be stable across time then
the top chimp had to be quite pro-social
so first of all had to engage in
sufficient reciprocal behavior so that
he had allies among other males right
because otherwise if you're like top
chimp and you're cavemen strong man type
and and you've established your
dominance merely as a matter of
intimidation and strength then if you
have an off day two of your slightly
weaker opponents can tear you to pieces
which is exactly what the chimps do
because they're quite brutal in there
there's no evidence that chimpanzees
have any internal regulation of the
violence that they'll use to shift
dominance hierarchy position
and so you end up castrated for example
by your opponents which is something
that de Waal noted in the Arnhem zoo so
he found that the stable chimp troops
had males at the helm who were who had
friendships because chimps actually have
social friendships really that can
stretch across many years decades even
and that they tracked them very well
very reciprocal in their behavior tended
to treat the females relatively well by
chimp standards and also tended to pay a
fair at fair amount of attention to the
infants which is an unbelievably
important finding right because it
indicates at a level that's below the
human let's say that there's an ethic
associated with leadership that isn't a
mere consequence of raw power and then
so that was the first thing that Higgins
pointed out and the second thing was
that he thought and and I haven't I
don't know how true this is yet he
thought that some of what the ethologist
hsihu had used the term dominance
hierarchy to apply to animals might have
been doing was using an intrinsically
Marxist framework to interpret animal
behavior and to overestimate the degree
to which dominance was actually the core
foundation of hierarchical organizations
even among animals and the first ones
the first objection he had that's
definitely the case this is true the
second one presenter is competence yeah
yeah well did the idea that that it's
pure power is an unstable basis for for
for stable hierarchy that's well
documented and I think that has probably
moved into the realm of empirically
verifiable fact the second one that the
initial idea that it was dominance per
se that was at the basis of hierarchical
arrangements was in part a quasi Marxist
interpretation or projection I think
that's disputable because I think what
happens is that as you go down the the
phylogenetic chain to simpler and
simpler animals it looks more and more
like power physical prowess essentially
is the determining factor it certainly
seems to be the case among lobsters for
example crustaceans they're of interest
because they have seen their third
lobster again they have relatively
simple nervous systems relatively
there's two
very complex with large neurons that are
easily observable Anna and a neuro
chemistry that differs from humans but
is the same is similar in very
interesting ways it may be an example of
using skills that aren't power based or
things like creativity to be able to
find well ways to food or get wellness
what you want you might want to figure
out how you would define competence and
so there's a psychometric answer to that
psychometric psychometrician Zoar
psychologists who are particularly
interested in measurement and then also
in measurement and prediction and so one
of the things you want to predict are
the various human outcomes like like
economic success let's say or subjective
well-being which is something that sam
Harris is quite excited about and or
general quality of life these things are
hard to measure but you can measure
economic success um
what and what you find is that well
there are a variety of features that
predict economic success in the Western
world then the most outstanding of those
are IQ so that's straight intelligence
and intelligence is something like
processing speed and working memory
capacity so it's the ability to
manipulate variables a number of
variables simultaneously at relatively
high speeds that's and they're abstract
variables and that's uh that you know
there's still people who debate about
the existence of IQ but they're called
fools fundamentally because look I mean
there's there's absolutely no doubt that
IQ is the most documented phenomena in
the social sciences except for one thing
there's one only one thing I've ever
seen that that has been measured more
powerfully and accurately and that was
the correlation between inequality
across counties in the United States and
male homicide rate because that
correlation is about 0.9 and you know
like that's just you never see that the
correlation between IQ and
success depending on any measure at
academic success learning speed economic
success success as a manager and
administrator success as an entrepreneur
your entrepreneur or creative agent the
correlation between that and IQ is about
0.5 which is about
three times roughly speaking
yeah three times two to three times as
powerful as the most typical next
powerful order of effects that social
scientists measure so IQs a walloping
effect so IQs the first one hardly
surprising I mean especially as the
environment gets more complex because IQ
predicts performance in complex jobs
better than it predicts performance in
simple jobs and a simple job is one
where you learn it and then you repeat
what you've learned whereas a complex
job is a job that changes everyday so I
suspect most of you in the audience have
complex job and performance in well I
suspect so you know me and maybe
performance with complex thinking as
well as long as the environment that
you're that you're operating in changes
on a relatively frequent basis then you
have to have an i high IQ to manage it
effectively that's basically what IQ
measures and then the next most relevant
predictor is trait conscientiousness
which is not a trait we understand at
all we have no measures of
conscientiousness that work
we've got a couple of weak ones but no
measures that really work better than
self-report and other report could be
meticulous be a good way to explain
conscientiousness
meticulousness is associated with
orderliness and orderliness is one of
the aspects of conscientiousness but
conscientious people the best way to sum
up a conscientious person is that
they're very good at keeping contracts
with themselves and others so what a
conscientious person will do is first of
all say that they'll do some things so
that's the first thing but then they'll
actually do it so they seem to be able
to and they seem to be it's crucial they
yeah it's crucial if it's especially
crucial if you're a manager and
administrator it's not so crucial if
you're an entrepreneur if you want to
hold yourself to achieving goals yeah
yeah well they tend to be if you want to
work your way up the competence
hierarchy probably a good way to do that
is to say I'm gonna do something and do
it yes well well that's the thing that
these are these this isn't this isn't
rocket science let's say
rocket surgery as one of the favorite
characters of a show I like in Canada
tends to say that that's the Trailer
Park Boys rocket surgery which i think
is really funny anyways I mean Laura
four so four buckets you know science
finding it's pretty damn self-evident
right smart people who work hard do
better and but what that's also what's
also really cool about that and this it
isn't viewed this way very often is like
let's say that you are going to
psychometrically validate the integrity
of an economic system so you'd say well
you take the smart people and and the
hard-working people and see if they do
better and if the answer is no then this
system is rotten right I mean doesn't
that make sense because you'd expect
you'd hope if a system is functioning
that faster harder working people would
be better at whatever it does and it
turns out that in our culture and in the
Western culture the correlation between
conscientiousness plus IQ you have to
wait the two and long term life success
is as high as 0.7 which is walloping
walloping correlation given how much
chance also contributes to success right
because you can be working hard and very
smart and then you get cancer and die
and that's the end of that like there
are lots of random events in life that
interfere with your movement forward and
so there's an errata Keable degree of
chance that that prediction is not going
to overcome plus we're not that good at
measuring success so there's error on
the success end of the measurement as
well but IQ and conscientiousness goes a
long ways yeah so and that's competence
you know and the other thing we might
think about with regards to defining a
competence hierarchy is imagine that one
of the things you want from the
operators within a hierarchy is that
they maintain the hierarchy and they
expand it so that it can include other
people right and so competence a good
measure of competence would be the
ability to work within the hierarchy
while you're also expanding maintaining
it and expanding it and so you that
means that you would want to set up an
economic system where smart hardworking
people were doing things that made other
people who weren't them rich too
hmm and I think we're actually pretty
good at that you know if you look at the
statistics here's a good one and if this
is why people shouldn't be as
pessimistic as they are likely it's a
good feeling to make other people
well-off and have their well-being but a
lot and lots of people I mean one of the
things I've really been struck by with
the people that I've known who were
hyper competent is that one of the
things they really like to do is to find
young people who need opportunities and
open doors for them I mean it's a it's a
it's a pleasure that's not well measured
you know but I know that like I've seen
that among the professors that I've
known that I really admired like they
really like to mentor graduate schools
and graduate students and develop their
careers and entrepreneurs in Silicon
Valley that I know the same thing and
good managers and administrators they're
not playing a zero-sum game like they're
not opening the doors to everyone I
wouldn't say but they're definitely
always looking around for competent
people who are young to provide
opportunities to and it's a real unsung
virtue of capitalism that that sort of
thing occurs and it's not rare so so so
well so back to the to the IQ and
conscientiousness connection is like
like with regards to the say the the
broad capitalist that broad capitalist
social and economic structure you know I
don't know if you guys know this but the
UN said is one of its millennial goals
in the year 2000 to have the rates of
poverty in the world by 50% within 15
years right and we hit that in 2012
three years ahead of schedule it was the
fastest decrease in human poverty that
has ever occurred in the history of the
planet by a massive margin and it hasn't
quit now obesity is a bigger problem now
than starvation it's like we should have
party in the street for that right
there's more fat people than there are
starving people you know it's a perverse
sort of victory but but it's a big one
and about three hundred thousand people
a day right now are being plugged into
the electrical grid and the
fastest-growing economies are in
sub-sahara Africa sub-saharan Africa
it's like there's some real reason to be
thinking things are going great in there
having Amazon and Holly Baba compete to
provide them with those goods that they
need every little bit yeah well they
have cell phone technology that's really
made a big difference and help stabilize
the currencies and help them identify
where the proper market is for their
goods and they're being plugged into
YouTube and watching Jordan be Peters
and videos now yes well what can I say
so Jordan Jordans on competence
hierarchies let's look it's better it's
better to think yeah it's better to
think of a well functioning human
hierarchy as one based on competence the
other thing like my colleague said to me
was that you don't want to overestimate
how much power people have let's say in
a corporate environment because it's not
obvious at all that the managers or the
executives for that matter except in the
rare cases where they're psychopathic
have fewer strictures who have well
sometimes you get Psychopaths that rise
to the top right I mean otherwise there
wouldn't be Psychopaths but it isn't
obvious that people higher up in a
competence hierarchy have fewer
strictures on their moral behavior than
people lower in the hierarchy right
because my sense is that responsibility
increases as you move up the hierarchy
and so and your degrees of freedom with
regards to moral attitude also tend to
decline because you're you know if
you're a manager of duffel maybe you
have 30 people working for you
and they each only have one manager
there's a lot of people that you're
responsible to and so and you can't miss
you can't mistreat your people
with any degree of consistency because
the good ones leave
the bad ones torture you to death and
the whole thing collapses across time
and so the whole idea that what you have
in a confidence hierarchy is power is
not a reasonable assumption as far as I
can tell that's a big deal right wisely
we've got to get that right well so it's
a big deal and the word competence is an
empowering word I've achieved the status
that I have
whoever speaking these words by
competence and then there's better mates
better food less disease etc to it climb
higher now since you since you bring
this up I think this is an important
point and that I really wanted to ask
you about which is that what percentage
of the competence hierarchy is
influenced by potentially an exertion of
oppression forgiving let me give you an
example for example let's go ahead and
take our friendly Lobster yeah let's
take the lobster for example let's say
the lobster is a sea floor dwelling
creature and the lobster has twenty
shelters but the lobster only inhabits
two of the shelters but it doesn't
enable the other lobsters to dwell or
reside in the other eighteen shelters
that it doesn't even use
just as an example
Laura I mean it's we could we could
think about this one of the things that
I've found very interesting about
looking at archetypal representations of
experiential reality is that they're
always balanced and so the fundamental
archetypal representation of the
hierarchy is the wise King and the
tyrant and every hierarchy can be
reasonably represented with narratives
involving the wise King and the tyrant
so the wise king is the part of the
hierarchy that sustains itself and
expands and includes more people right
so that's a functioning polity and the
tyrant is the fact that people operating
within that hierarchy can play zero-sum
games can be willfully blind can be
malevolent can play politics can cease
to be productive can manipulate the
system for their own devices and all of
that and it's obviously the case that
every human institution especially as
they scale falls prey to the tyrannical
part of the archetype that's why big
things fall apart and so when you say
well to what degree is a hierarchy to
what degree is a hierarchy emerged
because of tyrannical factors the answer
is well it depends on the hierarchy but
generally a non-trivial amount that
scales with size okay but that having
said that that doesn't to say that
something is partially corrupt is a lot
different than saying that it's totally
corrupt right there's this great story
for those of you that don't know it in
The Brothers Karamazov and the Atheist
Ivan who's the most compelling character
I would say most charismatic character
in the book is torturing his younger
brother
Alyosha who's a monastic novitiate about
religion and dogma and God and he's
trying to convince a lyosha that if
there is a god he's so cruel that he's
reprehensible in his fundamental element
and anyways he tells this story about
the Catholic Church and it's called the
the Grand Inquisitor it's a very very
famous story and in this story Christ
come
comes back to earth-2 Seville in Spain
at the height of the Spanish Inquisition
and he's he reappears and he's doing
miraculous things and you know
dividing up the loaves and feeding the
poor and healing the sick and being
miraculous and wonderful and the Grand
Inquisitor who runs the Spanish
Inquisition promptly has him arrested
and throws him in prison and then he
come and and and he's decides he's going
to be executed and he comes to visit him
at night and he says look you know you
were here 1500 years ago and you're you
were perfect and you put a moral burden
on human beings that was way too great
for anyone to carry and it's taken us
1500 bloody years to cobble together
something out of your insanely positive
example that normal human beings could
live with and we finally got it a little
bit under control and dampened it down
and here you are back again like setting
up an impossible example for people we
just can't have that we're gonna do you
in tomorrow and Christ listens and is
not particularly upset by all
appearances about what's happening and
then the Inquisitor who's an old man
gets up to leave and when he leaves
Christ stands up and kisses him on the
lips and the Inquisitor turns white with
shock and then leaves and when he leaves
he leaves the door open and that's the
brilliant part of the story because and
that's what made Dostoevsky such an
amazing genius I would say is even
though he could write a critique of the
Catholic Church let's say the Christian
Church is powerful and is intelligent as
the Grand Inquisitor he also noticed
that the dogmatic structure of the
church still left the still left the
door open for the divine individual it's
like you don't get a hierarchy without
getting a tyranny along with it you know
but but there's a hell of a difference
between the 30 or so countries in the
world where anyone with any sense would
want to live and the other hundred and
fifty where that are basically run by
barbaric thugs and it's important to
keep the distinction between those two
things in time it's like yeah we've got
some things that we should put together
and clean up and you know people are
discriminated against for unfair reasons
and that's to everyone's detriment
obviously but it's a multivariate
problem and the the the the the
positioning of someone in a hierarchy of
competence is in part due to their
what would you say to the historical
context within which that hierarchy has
emerged but to say it's all a
consequence of that is part of what I
regard as the radical leftist war on the
idea of competence itself because I
actually think that's the fundamental
narrative driving the real radical
leftists is that they hate the idea of
competence itself it's deeper than
Orwell's comment George Orwell's comment
in in Road to Wigan Pier where he said
well the problem with middle-class
british socialists is that they don't
like the poor they just hate the rich
just like Dada on man vicious vicious
diagnosis it's worse than that is that
is that the the radical leftist don't
like the oppressed they just hate the
competent I really believe that I think
it's I think it's unbelievably
pathological and dangerous it is so the
more nuanced conversations like these
rather than binary yes-or-no sort of
reductionist conversations around
complex topics like a competence
hierarchy that surface to fruition in
the media sphere I think over time we
will get to a point where more and more
people have deeply complex and nuanced
conversation about this Jordan how about
the genetic fitness landscape is this is
it fair to say that there are a bunch of
different competence hierarchies across
this plane of fitness competent well
there are there are one you know and you
know like one of the bubbles could be
who's ranked highest in the government
or one of them is who's ranked highest
in space or who's ranked highs in
genetic engineering and or whatever
field in whatever but that's why ideas
like multiple intelligence are so
attractive even though the idea of
multiple intelligence is wrong it's
clear no it's clearly it's clearly wrong
intelligence that factor analysis have
been done and we've known this since
like 1920 it's not disputable if you if
so here's how you make an IQ test it's
really easy and everyone should know
this because you need you need to know
how these things work so imagine that
you took a universal library of
questions any sort of question that
required abstraction to solve could be a
general knowledge question it could be a
vocabulary question could be a
mathematical question it doesn't matter
it could be a question about anything as
long as it requires abstraction to solve
so you have a universe
library of those questions then imagine
you took a hundred questions at random
from that Universal library and you gave
them to 500 people and then you just
totaled their scores right right wrong
total total scores then you rank ordered
the scores from highest performer to
lowest performer that's IQ that's all
there is to it
that's it and then what you'd find is if
you took another hundred questions from
the same library randomly selected and
gave them to the same 500 people and
you'd have to rank orders right from
from the top to the bottom the
correlation between the two rank orders
would be about point nine unbelievably
high it's unbelievably stable and now if
you correct that for age you get IQ
that's all there is to it
that's it and so well now so there's no
mutable intelligences and that's a
single factor if you do a factor
analysis which is a statistical
technique that tells you how many
different attributes that that rank
ordering possesses you get one factor so
it's one that's that not multiple now
there are multiple talents and there are
multiple temperaments and that's where
the Big Five model comes in so people
differ in extraversion and extroverts
are more likely to be good at sales jobs
people differ in negative emotionality
despite what the California Labor Board
ruled yesterday people differ in
sensitivity to negative emotion women
are more sensitive on average to
negative emotion than men and the effect
size of that is something like if you
took a random woman and a random man out
of the population and you had to lay a
bet on who had higher levels of anxiety
and emotional pain and you bet that it
was the woman you'd be right 60 percent
of the time so it's an interesting stat
because men and women are more the same
in emotional in in sensitivity to
negative emotion then different but
there's there's a there's a
said that the mean and what that also
means is that if you took the top 100
people top one and a hundred people who
are the most sensitive to negative
emotion they'd almost all be women now
you see the review see the inverse of
that in some sense with regards to
criminality so males are more aggressive
than females and it's about the same
difference if you take a random woman
and a random man out of the population
you had to bet on who was the most
aggressive if you bet it was the man and
you'd be right 60% of the time which
isn't that much of the time right it's
it's deviation from 50/50 but it's not
ninety ten it's just 60/40 but if you
take the one in a hundred persons who's
most aggressive and that's the person
you throw in prison by the way they're
all men nine out of ten of them are men
and so one of the things and this this
goes to the complexity argument that you
were talking about earlier that's hard
for people to have a multivariate
discussion because we like to collapse
things into single causes but it's also
hard for people to understand the
statistical reality of distributions
because you can have two distributions
that almost entirely overlap and have
walloping differences at the tails yeah
and the tails are where all the action
is like who cares how aggressive you are
as long as you don't shoot or stab
someone you get to be aggressive but if
you're so aggressive that you shoot or
stab someone then you end up in prison
and you're the person that we're
concerned with and maybe that's 1% of
the population it's like yeah well
they're all men and you see this happens
in less dramatic form too when you look
at phenomena like career selection so
it's just a data set released the other
day and this is the first time I'd seen
this showing quite clearly that as this
is a walk this is a remarkable finding
and it builds on some earlier research
which the California labor board also
decided with pseudoscience which is
absolutely 100% not pseudoscience that
is so wrong no serious scientists debate
the data that I'm describing that nobody
has debated it since like 1990 so it's
very well settled science
if you look at career choices between
men and women what you find is that
they're driven in large part by
temperamental differences so that would
be in the big five extraversion
neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness and also
by interest because the biggest
difference between men and women that's
been measured psychometrically forget
about the physical differences but the
psychological differences is difference
in interest and it's actually pretty big
and so men on average are more
interested in things and women on
average are more interested in people
and it's a one standard deviation
difference which is a big difference by
the standards of these sorts of
differences and it's enough to drive the
to drive a couple of phenomena phenomena
one most nurses are women phenomena two
most engineers are men why has nothing
to do or very little to do if any with
differences in mathematical reasoning
ability and I mean that's being tracked
too so if you take junior high kids men
and women girls and boys and you take
only those who are off the charts in
terms of their mathematical interest the
gender difference isn't that great
there's a tiny edge for boys but not
much and it's even disputable whether
that edge exists so let's assume it
doesn't for the sake of argument if you
track those kids across time what you
find is a disproportionate number of the
men go into the STEM fields and hardly
any of the women and the reason is
they're good at it but they're not
interested in it so in the end then you
might think well that's socio-cultural
why tweak we could change that it's like
no sorry research has already been done
what there's a so imagine you could rank
order countries by how gender-neutral
their socio-economic policies were and
then you put the Scandinavian countries
at the top for obvious reasons because
they've been pushing that for like three
decades for decades and have made a lot
of progress with it um the biggest
difference is in temperament and
interest in the world between men and
women are in the Scandinavian countries
and the data now have revealed that
there's a correlation between how
gender-neutral the country is and how
big the differences are between the men
and women and the difference is positive
not negative and then you think well is
that reliable science or are the
right-wing conservatives driving this
scientific agenda an answer to that is
there are no right-wing conservatives in
psychology
there are none I'm dead serious man I'm
dead serious about that so so here's why
this here's why this research is
reliable it's because the research is
reliable because the people who
generated the findings hated them they
hated the findings they were completely
biased in the other direction because
everyone everyone was hoping everyone
who's a social scientist was hoping that
as you flattened out the gender
differences in the sociological
landscape you would decrease the
personality differences the individual
differences and that's not what happened
you maximize them instead it's like oh
oh that that wasn't what we expected and
and believe me people just didn't run to
the publisher and publish these datasets
they were shocked by them and so they
replicated them and these have been
replicated across samples of tens of
thousands of people and and and dozens
of countries it's extraordinarily
reliable it is as far as I'm concerned
apart from the hard biological end of
this of psychology where there's some
unbelievably solid work done it's the
most solid social science that exists as
far as I can tell the psychometric data
and the reason I think that is when I
was starting my career um I was looking
for the most solid data because one of
the things I wanted to do was learn how
to predict how people's lives
transformed and changed and across time
and and what sort of level of
achievement they managed so I was
looking for the most reliable and valid
measures and it's clearly the
psychometric measures are the most
reliable and valid period no one
disputes that so except like you know
people in women's studies and that just
doesn't count so you know they they
don't have methodology so so the fact
that there's a dispute just doesn't
matter
yeah well so
fear look they have hypotheses right and
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
generating hypotheses
don't get me wrong like there's nothing
wrong with theory but when you start to
confuse theory with fact let's say then
there's real trouble and you know your
theory has to be constructed at least in
part so that you can make a prediction
of some sort so that you can measure
what your theory says that you can
measure and so that you can predict
something with it and then to see
whether or not your theory holds up
otherwise it's just a hypothesis and
that's fine but you don't get to impose
it on everyone else because you get to
state by Fiat that your hypothesis is
correct
it's it's
reprehensible to do that and then and
that's being done an awful lot an awful
lot so I always found it interesting to
think about why there weren't any groups
of men that were trying to increase the
amount of men that were in nursing or
dental hygienists education or an
education Social Work I always found
that interesting I always and then I
their lower pain the disciplines um
and then and then I recently started
thinking about this in terms of sports
with NFL and MBA and I was like hmm
there are just less Asian people and
Latino people and white people there's
just there's more black people that are
just better athletes and are we going to
decrease the standards for people of
different
from a better Asian or Latino to give
morning's is funny that the the the
discussion about gender differences in
occupational position let's say is
unbelievably narrow you know it tends to
focus on the highest corporate positions
that's not all of it but it tends to
focus on the highest corporate positions
or the highest paid positions but
certainly it's quite interesting if
you're if you're into this sort of thing
I suppose to go online and just look up
the Labor Statistics from from the
American federal government because they
they rank order occupations by gender
you know proportion and but bricklayers
are that's that that's the occupation
that's the most gender skewed there's
like no female bricklayers and but no
one cares about that and it's kind of
interesting well no but it is
interesting because it's not like
bricklayers don't make a good living you
know like the skilled trades people make
a damn good living but heavy machinery
operators very few women there too so
but the percentage of work-related
deaths 93% well that's a problem yeah I
mean that there's a bunch of reasons why
men make more money on average than
women do and one of them is that they're
they're more willing to work outside
that's one they're more willing to move
that's another they're they work longer
hours and if you work 13% more hours you
make 40% more money on that that's the
stats oh so that the effect of overtime
is nonlinear 13% more hours forty
percent more income yeah
Wow yeah yeah yeah well you can you
think that's a good example of how you
know let's say you have a bunch of
employees and you're trying to
differentiate them for promotion like
and let's say they're all operating
within a relatively narrow band perhaps
they aren't but let's say for this
example they are it's like well the
person who puts out 10% more
self-evidently
so well this guy's around like 10% more
that that would be what about next year
45 minutes a day something like that he
goes the extra mile while he's going to
get the promotion and so you also get
this like it also looks and this is
worth thinking about too and this is
part of the Pareto distribution problem
is that six
is disproportionately rewarded
it's not linear so as you start to
succeed the problem each success
nonlinearly increases the probability of
the next success right so the doors open
yeah yeah yeah that's right
and not one door but they open
exponentially right exactly and so and
as you fail they close exponentially so
you might think well sick failure
success linear it's like no failure
success right so once you start to fail
good luck to you right because each
failure increases the probability of the
next failure in a nonlinear mash fashion
and that really if you're on a downhill
trend man that's really vicious and it's
hard to get out of it you see that
happened to big companies when they
start to go into a death spiral they
can't pull themselves out of it but by
the same token when you start to succeed
each success increases the probability
of the next one you actually even see
that with lobsters so back to the
crustaceans well are they so interesting
that some of these things are so
fundamental that they appear so low in
the phylogenetic chain so if you if you
tally up you watch a lobster engage in
sequence sequential dominance disputes
so basically physical challenges
his probability if he loses the problem
if he loses a battle the probability
that he'll lose the next battle is
higher than you would expect if you just
derived a linear function that was a
consequence of the tally of his previous
victories and losses so because he's
lost he's more likely to lose harder the
next time but if he wins he's
statistically more likely to win so and
that also drives well that's a
fundamental issue too that drives the
disproportionate distribution of
productive goods and material resources
which is a very big problem it's another
thing you need to have an intelligent
discussion about in our deficit
definitely we're going to get there in
this conversation as well so just before
we wrap up the point about Big Five and
gender I have a thought about this and
it involves a company that is very close
to us here in the Bay Area Google and
the question about
Google is could it potentially be
the interest of a company to want to
bring diverse people from around the
world in to increase the creativity of
their output depends on how you define
diverse but I would say you guys have
already done that in Silicon Valley it's
like well how many people how many
people in Silicon Valley are from the
Indian Institute of Technology it's like
god they're everywhere you know and and
no wonder well so that's it but that's
cognitive that's that's cognitive
ability like look well some new types of
it is someone that's birthed in a
different part of the world yeah that
has a different upbringing that could
potentially bring something unique a
unique person has no evidence for that
whatsoever there's no there's no there's
no evidence for that that is not how you
get that's not the right definition of
diversity but could it also be
potentially that we are not measuring
and focusing on that in order to find
that data no no it's not it's not
because look measuring success is not an
easy thing you think it should be
meritocracy no matter what period
no there's there's always a fly in the
ointment oh wow they are there is there
so the other thing there's a good book
that I would recommend reading called
the great leveler by Walter shy del it's
a new book relatively new book and he
details out the he details out the in
erotic ability of inequality
so part of the problem with this process
that we just described where success
breeds success and failure breeds
failure is that the people who are
succeeding get a disproportionate share
of the resource high let's say so and
you know everyone knows that about money
right because the 12 richest people in
the world 85 richest people in the world
have as much money as the bottom 2
billion which seems well let's say
unfair now it's certainly unequal now
whether it I believe is lower than your
statistic is that eight richest have
equal to the bottom 3.5 billion yeah
well it's probably worse than it was
when I looked at this about three years
ago so but it doesn't it doesn't matter
because you get the point but it's um
it's not crazy but the thing is is that
this is not something that only applies
to money it applies to everything that's
creatively produced so the same rule
applies to number of records sold by
recording artists the same rule applies
to number of books sold by novelists the
same rule applies to number of goals
scored by NHL hockey players the same
rule applies to the population of cities
and the mass of stars and the size of
trees in the in the jungle it's like the
inequality problem is way more
troublesome again than mere capitalism
it's a terrible problem and shy Dells
work which is really really interesting
he's traced back inequality ten fifteen
thousand years using you can do it for
example let's say you find a Neolithic
burial site and there's 200 people in it
so these people would be buried with
their possessions and obviously some of
them decay but some of them don't and
like some of them are buried with gold
well hardly any of them and the tiny
proportion of people who are buried with
gold are buried with a lot of gold so
you can even derive a Gini coefficient
estimate which is an estimate of
inequality from burial sites and it
looks like as soon as you get a surplus
you get inequality and that's a rough
thing a because you might think well
even in hunter-gatherer societies where
there's no surplus there's still
inequality because there's inequality of
friendship there's inequality of health
and there's inequality of sexual access
and those things are they are not
trivial
but when you're thinking about it purely
economically you start to get an
inequality as soon as you get a surplus
you think oh that
interesting so there's a natural rule
which is surplus generates inequality
alright so how do you solve that and shy
Dells book says well that's easy you
just get rid of the surplus
right and that's not good so like he
found and so one of the things he did
was statistical analysis because one of
the things he might ask is well let's
say you have your measures of inequality
and then you can track them around the
world and you can track whether or not
the inequality is generated by a
right-wing government or a left-wing
government and then you might hope well
the left-wing governments would
ameliorate inequality there's no
evidence for that at all it doesn't look
like inequality is with it it doesn't
look like the amelioration of inequality
is within the purview of political
organization and you'd like you should
not here that with any degree of
happiness whatsoever because the social
science on inequality is also clear as
inequality levels increase societies
destabilize and the best indicator of
that I already mentioned that that was
work that was done by Martin daily and
margul Wilson at McMaster University in
Canada they're really interested in what
drove male homicide because most
homicide is male male-on-male it's
mostly young males it's mostly within
race and it's mostly status competition
right so and the status competitions get
intense where inequality increases so
where everyone's poor so if you rank
order American States and Canadian
provinces by inequality the poorer
provinces where everyone's poor there's
no male aggression and the rich
provinces and states where everyone's
rich there's no male it male homicide
but the states and provinces where
inequality is high the male homicide
rate starts to climb up and it's
probably the most aggressive males who
get most aggressive most rapidly when
inequality increases so there's a
psychological component but inequality
drives male homicide 0.9 is the
correlation which means that you
actually don't need any other
explanation for male homicide maybe you
throw in alcohol just just as it as an
extraneous variable you don't need any
other explanation for the male homicide
rate than inequality it's a staggering
work it's absolutely staggering work and
so the the thing is is that a
meritocracy will drive inequality and
then you have a problem because people
stack up at zero and they can't get out
of zero because that's what happens as
inequality increases people think about
when you're playing Monopoly you know
the game
that's a perfect example of how
inequality emerges everybody is equal to
begin with everybody basically plays a
random game because monopoly is
basically a random game I mean there's
some skill in it but not much so so it's
a random game so what happens when
everyone starts equal and you play
around in game one person ends up with
everything everyone else stacks up at
zero now shy Dells book basically shows
the only way out of that is various
forms of war including revolution and
epidemics that's it that's the only
thing he's been able to track that and
and what happens is well you level
everyone and then inequality decreases
it's like well okay that doesn't seem
like a really great solution sordin this
seems to be even more and more pressing
with the proliferation of artificial
intelligence robotics genetic
engineering neural prosthetics
nanotechnology and the race between
China and the United States and Russia
colonizing Mars what is going how do we
actually end up coming to a global
consensus on what to do as eight people
equate and wealth to the bottom 12 I
don't see why we have to have an
intelligent discussion about this
because on the one hand it's pretty
obvious that modern economies are doing
a damn good job of lifting people
rapidly out of abject poverty okay but
at the same time the inequality of it of
economic the economic inequality by some
measures at least is increasing and that
does have this destabilizing effect and
so then the question is what what do you
do about it well it's really hard
because
in a meritocracy part of that's driven
by segregation by intelligence
and then that's likely exaggerated by
of computational power because a really
smart person with a computer is way
smarter than a really smart person
without a computer and is written and is
way smarter than a person who isn't so
smart either with or without a computer
right so the computational technology
looks like it's a multiplier like I'm
sure many of you already know know
because there's a huge difference
between someone who can really use a
computer and someone who's barely
computer literate and lots of way more
people are barely computer literate
literate than you know so here's a good
stat this is like I'm really familiar
I've really familiarized myself with the
IQ literature and it's a dismal horrible
literature but but you really need to
know it because it's a solid literature
unfortunately and one of the most
terrifying statistics I ever came across
was one detailing out the rationale of
the United States Armed Forces for not
allowing the inductor you can't induct
anyone into the Armed Forces in the u.s.
if they have an IQ of less than 83 okay
so let's just take that apart for a
minute because it's a horrifying thing
so the US Armed Forces has been in the
forefront of intelligence research since
World War one because they were onboard
early with the idea that especially
during wartime when you're ramping up
quickly that you need to sort people
effectively and essentially without
prejudice so that you can build up the
officer corps so you don't lose the damn
war okay so there's real motivation to
get it right right because it's life and
death issue so they used IQ they did a
lot of the early psychometric work on IQ
okay so that's the first thing they're
they're motivated to find an accurate
predictor so they settled on IQ the
second thing was the United States Armed
Forces also really motivated to get
people into the Armed Forces peacetime
or wartime wartime well for obvious
reasons peacetime because well first of
all you got to keep the Armed Forces
going and second you can use the Armed
Forces during peacetime as a way of
taking people out of the underclass and
moving them up into the working-class or
the middle class right you can use it as
a training mechanism and and so there's
and left and right can agree on that you
know it's it's a reasonable way of
promoting social mobility so again the
Armed Forces even in peacetime is very
motivated to get as many people in as
they possibly can and it's difficult as
well you it's not that easy to recruit
people so you don't
throw people out if you don't have to so
what's the upshot of all that well after
a hundred years essentially of of
statistic careful statistical analysis
the Armed Forces concluded that if you
had an IQ of 83 or less
there wasn't anything you could possibly
be trained to do in the military at any
level of the organization that wasn't
positively counterproductive
okay you think well so what 83 okay yeah
one in ten
one in ten
ten people and that what that really
means that as far as I can tell is if
you imagine that the military is
approximately as complex as the broader
society which i think is a reasonable
proposition then there's no place in our
cognitively complex society for one in
ten people so what are we going to do
about that the answer is no one knows
say well shovel money down the hierarchy
it's like the problem isn't lack of
money means sometimes that's the problem
but the problem is rarely absolute
poverty it's rarely that it is sometimes
but rarely it's not that easy to move
money down the hierarchy so first of all
it's not that easy to manage money so
it's a vicious problem man and so it's
hard to train people to become creative
adaptive problem solvers impossible you
can't do it you can't do it you can tear
fixes Colliers ability but but you can't
you can't do that it's training doesn't
work it's working six months but it
could work in six years no it doesn't
work sorry it doesn't work like the dado
and that's crystal clear as well look I
can give you an example so I know a
bunch of people who run MBA programs and
I've had discussions with them because
the thing about an MBA program is this
is if it's selective it's really hard to
get in it's like getting into Harvard
it's really hard to get into Harvard you
have to have an IQ that places you least
at the 99th percentile and then you have
to be really good at at least one or two
other things so it's really hard to get
in okay so you think well why hire a
Harvard graduate well it's the quality
of the education it's like no it's not
it's the fact that it's really hard to
get in all of the value of the Ivy
League education is in the screening
before the before the before the
education starts now that doesn't mean
that people people go to Harvard they
get educated but they'd get just as
educated if they went somewhere else
first of all it's like every University
contains more information than any
student can ever possibly process if
you're super smart you can be dropped
into a State College somewhere a low
level State College you spend four years
in the library you know like what are
you gonna do read the whole library no
right so so and the data on this is
quite clear it's like
and it's the same with private schools
the reason that people who go to private
schools do better than people who go to
public schools is because generally
speaking the people who go into private
schools are smarter it's not the
education that's any better
and so we radically overestimate the
degree to which training works so now
you can train people to be stupid that's
but training them to be smarter than
they are is really really really hard so
it like I said it's a dismal literature
and liberals see the Liberals think
everyone's roughly equal and there's a
job for everyone you just have to train
them it's like no wrong and the
Conservatives think well there's a job
for everyone if they just get off their
ass and look and work it's like no no
that's wrong too
even though if you work that's better
and well so that that's on the
conservative end but the Liberals won't
take into account individual differences
well obviously that's part of what the
whole politically correct discussion is
about it's like everyone's the same it's
like yeah they're not you know when I
find it
it's really it's really annoying I would
say like I love love to come to Silicon
Valley I've been here many many times
and like it's really something to come
here and and and meet there's so many
people here who off the scales
intelligence and they're all you know
clustered together which is why this
place is so unbelievably rich and so
unbelievably productive one of the
reasons but it's very it's also very
annoying that it's so left-leaning
because one of the things that the
left-leaning Silicon Valley geniuses
should understand that is that they're
the beneficiary of a genetic lottery
mmm-hmm and they should take that
seriously it's like yeah you worked hard
yes you're entrepreneur oh yes you're on
point you put in your sixty hours a week
you know you do everything you could do
you have an IQ of 150 and like that's
not your doing right that's something
that happened to you and so you can't be
saying well it's it's all me it's like
no it's not it's all you and the genius
that you were granted
as an infant it's that's it that's
what's driving it now that that doesn't
mean I think that people of
disproportionate intelligence shouldn't
be rewarded disproportionately it's
possible that they should because it
might be in the best interest of
everyone else to dump as much money as
possible to the top 2% of the cognitive
strata because they're going to be most
generative with it and so and even if
it's not fair because you might say well
just because you won the genetic lottery
does that mean that you should have more
money than anyone else it's like well
not on the grounds of fairness but if
you have to distribute money well who
are you going to distribute it to you
know and I think Toth was it Ted who ran
CNN Ted Turner he estimated that if you
tried as hard as you could in your
entire life there was no way that you
could spend more than four hundred
million dollars and so let's say you
have more money than that at your
disposal well hopefully you're going to
do some halfways intelligent things with
it and hopefully you'd expect that the
more intelligent people would do more
than halfway intelligent things with it
so if you have to have unequal
distribution then a meritocracy is
probably the best way to do it but it
still leaves you with this terrible
problem which is what do you do with all
the people who stack up to zero and the
answer isn't have contempt for them
because they don't work as hard as you
it's like yeah a bunch of them don't you
know because conscientiousness also
predicts success so among the poor there
are people who don't work you know but
everyone underestimate the contribution
of cognitive ability so it's a rough man
and we don't take it seriously and we
don't know what to do about it and yeah
it's clear that as inequality increases
societies destabilize that's clear
so it's something that has to be dealt
with and but we don't know how to deal
with it we don't know how to efficiently
move resources to the bottom end of the
competence hierarchy so that things
don't destabilize so you know and I've
worked with people lots of people who
are who are at the bottom end of the
hierarchy in my clinical practice and
you know like cocaine addicts for
example low eye low IQ cocaine addicts
not not all cocaine addicts have low IQ
by the way but you know it's it's just
uh it's it's a triple whammy let's say
cuz if you're a cocaine addict you
probably also an alcoholic and so if
you're a cocaine addict and you're an
alcoholic and you're sort of on the low
end of the cognitive distribution it's
like you have pretty damn rough life
there's a lot of things going wrong for
you and you're really lucky if you're
flat broke because as soon as you get
money you are so done you cannot believe
it
so like when your unemployment check
comes in and you're a cocaine addict
alcoholic who isn't employed the
probability that three days later you're
going to end up facedown in the ditch is
really really high so don't be thinking
like it's not so simple that you can
just dump money down the competence
hierarchy to the to the people who are
in the underclass and expect that that's
going to have a salutary effect I don't
think there's any evidence for that
whatsoever like money is not an easy
resource to use productively so is a
class-based speciation something to be
concerned about
um elaborate on that a little bit what
do you mean exactly well by class-based
speciation meaning there's already a
tremendous amount of wealth that is
accumulated within such a small
percentage of people and whether it be
through a bifurcation of split of a
couple billion people off of the human
species or it could be a trifurcation we
don't know how many splits there may be
whether that I don't know if it's
something to worry about or something to
hope for
I mean this time scales are so large
that it's probably not relevant to
individuals potentially something to
hope for in the evolutionary trajectory
of the well you kind of hope that people
get smarter might might get smarter
across time I guess we would hope that
might be a good thing I mean it's not
self-evident so if it is a lottery if it
was a roll of the dice to be born where
we are don't we also feel that it could
have been a roll of the dice to be born
in a place less fortunate there for sure
would you feel that I think that's why
the you know even if you're successful
people often feel guilty because of
inequality and then no wonder your
ultimate calling in terms of the width
of religion and with with finding
self-actualization and meaning within
you is to like you say eradicate
suffering is something that is give so
much meaning to life well the sometimes
people in less fortunate circumstances
experience lots of suffering with lack
of food or water or shelter or basic
biological needs and so then therefore
doesn't it feel like within this
potential class-based speciation with
wealth that there should be some sort of
assistive course
where's okay and now that's all for the
basis do that well so there's a couple
of things there I mean to the degree
like you know I've been a vocal opponent
of the radical left and I can't detest
them enough really is this a fundamental
is to find my fundamental position but
but that doesn't mean that I don't think
that a functioning polity requires a
left in a right-wing absolutely and the
reason it requires a left wing is
because inequality is real and it has to
be addressed it has to be addressed for
all the reasons that you described but
but that having said that there are ways
to go about addressing it
that are clearly counterproductive and
those were tried to great destructive
power in the 20th century and I don't
really think we need to do that again
the corollary to that is we don't know
what the productive means are now I've
been thinking a lot about that you know
and I'm thinking well how do you solve
the problem of inequality and it has to
be something like the moral burden on
those who are successful has to be
increased it's something like that and I
think you see that I mean I think I
wrote this to you that what's the
significance of purchasing a third yacht
rather than maybe hiring 50 people to
solve a problem well it's it's hard
these things aren't so simple you know
like let's say that you decided to go
out to a restaurant and your meal is
five hundred dollars and you might think
well that's reprehensible and well
perhaps you don't think that's
reprehensible but the thing is it's not
a bad way of dispersing extra money so
it's not that obvious what rich people
should do with their money that's
beneficial and you think well should you
buy a third yacht because do you really
need it and well that's a particularly
perhaps a particularly egregious example
but it's not like you're not employing
people when you do that you shouldn't
stuff the money in your mattress we
could say that right because that's just
pure hoarding but most people who have
money aren't like Scrooge McDuck they
don't have a money bin that they swim in
right their money well that's that's the
kind of that's the kind of clueless
picture of wealth I mean most people who
have money their money is out there
doing things it's not like they're it's
not like it's in their bedroom you know
it's in in gold coin form so they're not
hoarding it in exactly the same way that
perhaps people used to hoard wealth when
it wasn't as what was tracted and and
and functional in its own terms out
there in the economy is usually working
for them making them more money yeah but
it's also doing a bunch of other things
you know and if you're a bad money
manager even if you're wealthy your
money tends to disappear very rapidly
that's another thing that's really worth
knowing is that like there is a 1% and
that 1% does have a disproportionate
amount of the money and 1% of that 1%
has an even more disproportionate amount
of the money it scales all the way up
the of the measurement spectrum let's
say but there's actually quite a bit of
mobility within that 1% so you have a
10%
chance in your lifetime in the United
States of being in the top 1% for at
least a year now that's not like a
hundred percent chance but it's 1 in 10
it's not dismal you know so partly what
you hope for is that there's some
genuine upward mobility but then I think
the other thing that you hope for is
that people who are disproportionately
successful take it upon themselves to do
everything they possibly can to do
whatever they can that's the best
possible thing to do with their money
and you know I'm kind of an admirer of
Bill Gates for a variety of reasons but
he's doing a really good job of putting
the boots to the five world the world's
5 worst transmissible diseases you know
and that's going quite nicely you know
they're making some real polio is just
about defunct they're making some real
progress with malaria like there's
almost nothing that could possibly be
done for Africa that would be more
useful than to get rid of malaria
sleeping sickness would be another one
that would be really useful to allow to
eradicate and so I would say that the
long-term solution assuming that there
is one to the problem of inequality is
that people who are disproportionately
fortunate let's say or successful or
both take it upon take the moral duty of
doing the best possible good that they
can with the money that they generate
great but the other thing I think that's
sort of interesting about that is I
actually don't think there's anything
more interesting to do with your money
the direct it's like can you think of
anything more interesting to do with
your money than to find a really
difficult problem that causes a bunch of
people suffering and then try to fix it
it's like amazing if you have a clue
that's got to be a little better than a
third yacht yeah so no it's pretty low
well it's kind of a low like that
conspicuous consumption thing at some
point it's just if you have any sense at
some point that's just not very
impressive could could another way to
address the potential class-based
speciation be the education of the child
and by the principles of let's say that
over the last hundred billion people
that have lived and died to build this
beautiful world we live in today with
all the food and water ubiquity and the
government's and the economies that
there every child that's being stamped
out into this world might have a little
tiny missing chip on their shoulder and
that missing chip might be things like
their parents explaining to them what
evolution is or what their
nah to me what their heart and their
brain is their body maybe what morality
is things like that if maybe every child
is born with a little bit of something
like that do you think there's something
like that Jordan yeah this you know like
that's done right this thing is
connecting everyone to everything and so
the probability that people are going to
be get whatever education they want in
the next 30 years is overwhelmingly high
so I think in some sense
that problem is being solved as rapidly
as it can possibly be
being solved that is doesn't mean people
should stop trying to find more and more
effective ways of educating I think that
would be our there's some general basic
principles that you think of parents
should teach a child but obviously
within the rules of life but it may be
something about evolution or something
about their own Anatomy and well I think
that I I think that there are all sorts
of things that parents who are good
parents teach their children I mean part
of what twelve rules for life is about
is about that's like a universal ethic
in some sense there I think that there
is a there's dawning realization among
members of the biologically oriented
community let's say that there is
something like an emergent ethic that's
evident in biological systems and one of
the most outstanding examples of that I
would say is apart from the work that de
Waal has done with chimpanzees showing
the beginnings of an ethic at least in
in the behavioral sense the beginnings
of an ethic among chimpanzees is work
that's been done with rats and so yog
panksepp for example who wrote a book
called effective neuroscience which I
would highly recommend it's a real work
of genius you blew my mind with Piaget
by the way with the way the rats know
that's pay except that that was no
Piaget found that out found that out in
children so Oh panksepp was the
scientist who discovered that rats
laughs that's right and you think well
that's not a big deal it's like actually
it is a really big deal because it shows
that it shows commonality of the
positive emotion systems across
biological strata essentially so it's
actually a really big deal and he found
that if you tickle routes with an eraser
they laugh ultrasonically yeah so you
have to slow it down to hear them and
the reason he would figure that out was
because he was trying to figure out why
if you take rat pups away from their
mother and feed them and give them
enough water they still die so they die
unless you massage them with well he is
the pencil eraser that's what because
it's kind of soft it seems to work
without harming the rats little rat pups
and if you rub them with pencil eraser
then they'll thrive and that was
actually translated very rapidly into
practical research because it turns out
that if you have
mature infant it's in our incubator they
often lose weight a which is a really
bad thing because they're supposed to be
gaining weight but if you massage them
three times a day for ten minutes then
they'll gain weight about as fast as
they do in utero and they leave the
hospital on average five days earlier
and the beneficial cognitive and
physiological effects are still
detectable six months down the road so
walloping it's a walloping effect and so
it turns out that one of the things
panksepp sorted out was that human that
touches a human need it's not a
secondary need it's a primary need like
like food and water
the childhood development yeah yeah well
and he was also a big proponent of
rough-and-tumble play because he found
out that in rats that rough-and-tumble
play especially among juvenile males
catalyzes pre-frontal development and
that rat pups who are male that aren't
allowed to engage in rough-and-tumble
play show prefrontal hypo development
and you can then treat them with Ritalin
which is the ADHD drug just in case
you're wondering so that's a very dismal
line of scientific research but also
very promising
so what panksepp also found and this is
another piece of information that really
blew me away when I first first read
about it
was so hee hee hee
banks have discovered the play circuitry
in mammals and that's also a big deal
right that's like discovering a
continent to discover a dedicated
circuitry to a set of complex biological
functions that's a big deal man and so
when he was investigating play behavior
among rats he noticed that juvenile
males in particular would work to
wrestle and they wrestled really a lot
like ball human children or like cumin
children and dogs wrestle and rat spin
each other so what Pink's have found
first was that and other scientists as
well but I'll use him as a shorthand was
that rats would work to enter a play
arena where they knew they were going to
be allowed to wrestle with a appear and
that's kind of how you figure out if a
rat wants to do something right you make
them button press for it or pull on
something and then you can measure how
fast you press the button or how hard a
poll and you can get some estimate of
how motivated he is and routs pretty
damned motivated to enter into a play
arena and so if one rat enters into a
play arena and another rat does and the
one rat is 10 percent bigger than the
other
then in like 9 out of 10 cases the big
rat can pin the little rat and in the
first bout then pinning establishes
dominance this is kind of an interesting
commentary on scientific methodology too
because let's say that you are
investigating rat behavior and you were
trying to draw conclusions and you only
paired rats together once you'd assume
the big rat dominates its physical size
that does the domination and that's the
purpose of play but that isn't right
because playing let it win of relates a
long way is something that iterates
right you don't play with a person only
once you play with them well who knows
for how long right if it's a
relationship that lasts decades then
it's decades of reciprocal interaction
so thanks F and his colleagues and the
other scientists who are working on this
paired the rats repeatedly so these are
iterated games and the rules of an
integrated game aren't the same as the
rules of
off-key and that might actually be the
basis for a universal ethic is that
there are rules for iterated games and
what Panks have found was that ok so the
big rat is now super ordinate to the
little rat
now when you repair them the little rat
has to ask the big trout to play that's
the rule so the big rat gets to sit
there like he's cool and the little rat
has to hop up like like a dog that's
asking you to play and sort of bounce
around you all know what that looks like
dog kind of puts his rear end up in the
air kind of hops a little bit and that
means like well come on
human not me you know and if you have
any sense you know how to do that and
and you can even understand when a dog
does it and the dog if he socialized can
understand when you're doing it right
because a well socialized dog is you
kind of you kind of go like this and
then he does the same thing and you
whack him on the side of the head a
little bit he growls and puts his you
know your hand in his mouth but he
doesn't bite it but he sounds like he's
going to the dog knows what the hell's
going on unless it's completely unless
it's raised by a behavioral psychologist
which is the worst behaved dog I ever
saw was a dog that was raised by a
behavioral psychologist so anyway sorry
about that but so anyways so you pair
these rats together and what you find is
that so the little rat has to ask the
big rat to play in the big rattle like
you know break is cool and then wrestle
and then if you pair them repeatedly
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win 30% of the time the little rat will
no longer ask him to play like and I
read that it was like little electrical
storm went off in my bag is what are the
me - well it's so good so I'm so
absolutely unbelievable is that well
there you have it emergent ethic of
reciprocity all you need to do is pair
animals together in reciprocal play
boats and you have an emergent
reciprocity and then you think well okay
so that's the basis for social
interaction is that reciprocity there's
a bit of an advantage to thee to the big
rat but not a huge advantage say well
that's the beginning of an ethic and you
say well human beings that ethic emerged
at the biological level and then human
beings watched it develop and told
stories about it that's where the
stories came from and then out of the
stories we coded an explicit ethic and
that's where the philosophy of ethics
came from but it emerged from the bottom
up something
she predicted like 150 years ago he said
well you know we'll find that there was
an emergent ethic that emerged
biologically and then was later mapped
and so that was just well let's just
absolutely beyond belief very likely
true and points the way to something
like
well an archetypal ethics certainly one
of reciprocity which which I think the
fundamental are archetypal ethic it's
like
well here's another example Jordan maybe
just because we own we would not touch
on a bunch of other okay appoints as
well I believe we're we're amazingly in
depth in this is so cool
well universalistic is important as it
turns out exactly
let me tell just a brief story okay
alright cuz this is also this is also
extremely important because it shows
where the classical economist real story
brief brief Jordan Peterson yeah I know
it's not likely so let's play a trading
game okay so you two can play this
trading game so here's the deal it's
very simple I'm gonna give you a hundred
dollars I'm not actually but yeah I'm
gonna give you a hundred dollars and you
can offer some of it to your partner in
the game but the rule is if she says no
you don't get anything and neither does
she
and you only get to make one offer so
okay here's your hundred dollars how
much he can offer her
40 okay would you take 40 okay then now
that's interesting very good that's
perfect okay so first of all the classic
economist would say you should offer her
a dollar why well because she might as
well take a dollar because she gets a
dollar yeah and you want to maximize
your own return so you get 99 dollars
it's like
what happens when you do that what
happens is that is never what people do
they usually offer approximately 50%
yeah what's and and if they don't then
the other person refuses yeah now then
you might think well let's say you
matched a rich person and a poor person
and you said okay give the rich person
100 and they offer the poor person a
dollar what does the poor person say you
think well yeah yeah I need the dollar
state they say no go to hell I'm not
doing it because and they're more likely
the poor person is more likely to refuse
the lower offer than a rich person is
completely running completely contrary
to the predictions of classical
economist you play that game across the
world it's pretty much 50/50 and that's
so interesting because it's another
example of that emergent ethic it's like
well part of the reason you'd say no and
why know is correct is because you don't
play one trading game you play a
lifetime of trading games and the right
answer to the question of how to play a
lifetime of trading games is to not
settle for less than 50% but you could
also make a case that if you're the
giver rather than receiver if you're
playing an iterated game you might want
to offer $60 $60 because especially if
your reputation is being broadcast
because let's say your goal isn't to get
forty dollars which is what you'd be
left if you offered 60 your goal is to
let everybody know that if they play
with you you give them 60 and you get 40
and then what happens is like well let's
take a vote on who wants to play with
who it's like you want to play with the
person who offers you ten or do you want
to play with the person who offers you
60 and then the person who's a little
more generous than reciprocal you know
50 50 would be reciprocal maybe you
should err on the side of generosity why
well easily easy people will line up to
play with you so then the question is do
you want to win the game or do you want
to win the set of games right and I
think I think there's rules that govern
the set of all possible games and it's
the rules that govern the set of all
possible games that constitute something
like an emergent ethic so anyway so
that's a very useful thing to know it's
a very useful thing to know it is can
you give a couple quick ones of those
potential universal ethics that govern
the set of games well I think I think
that's the big one I think I think the
big one is you approximate reciprocity
but it would be better it'd be better if
you can figure out how to I think you
its receptor esse prosody with erring on
the side of generosity because there's
just no downside to that in an iterated
game it's like I'm gonna borrow what I
do when I grade papers with students for
example as I grade them and then I had
5% it's like well maybe I made a mistake
so I'll err on the side of generosity
right and why not do that in your
reciprocal interactions that doesn't
mean you're letting people take
advantage of you right it's not a matter
of a weakness in your negotiating
strategy because there's no excuse for
that that's just that's a losing game
that but if you could take 50 percent or
70 percent and you decide to be generous
it's like well
you still have to be awake so that
you're not being messed about with by
people who are a little bit on the
psychopathic and you know you don't want
to be foolish about it but reciprocal
plus generous that's a hell of a good
start so can we do quick dive into
science and God because I want I want to
know one quick good let's let's try so
let's try 10 science sufficiently
consistently self-actualize humans
well okay let because with with your
with God with religion people find some
sort of self-actualization
science be a source of
self-actualization or no doubt allow it
the way that we normally construe
science like if you look at let's make
that concrete for for a minute
when I teach my students my personality
Klaus and we concentrate a fair bit on
clinical theories because I'm a
clinician one of the things I make clear
to them is that neither medicine nor
clinical psychology are sciences
there there there variants of
engineering
attempting to build something there's an
end in mind there's an ethical end in
mind right I mean what you do when
you're a clinical psychologist is try to
help people make their lives better now
you might say well you're trying to make
them more mentally healthy but actually
that's a weaker description than that
you're trying to make their lives better
because sometimes as a clinical
psychologist you see people who are you
know they're normal in their health but
they would like their lives to be better
there's a knop obviously there but and
that introduces the ethical realm and
you might be able to use scientific
techniques in order to determine which
of the strategies you use to try to make
your life better are working but it's
not obvious that you can use scientific
principles to decide what constitutes
better to begin with problem you know I
don't see any evidence that you can well
how about the science right let's take
morality from its purview at the
methodological level well okay let's
take an example of cancer and science
solving suffering by providing solutions
to cancer yeah well should you devote
money to cancer education
that's see that's where the problems
start to come is that you can't you
can't make an a priori decision you
can't make an informed decision about
where the ethical where the the
scientific attention should focus itself
it's not an easy thing to do at some
point the decisions have to be there
either arbitrary they're made by they're
made by techniques that seem to be
outside of the scientific purview let me
give you an example so I read this book
by an ex KGB agent who had detailed out
some of the extent of the Soviet
biological warfare program back in the
1980s and one of the things the Soviet
scientists were trying to do according
to this guy was to weaponize biological
infectious biological agents it actually
turns out to be harder than we suspected
thank God and what they were trying to
do was cross smallpox with Ebola and
it's because Ebola is like seriously
fatal and smallpox is seriously
contagious and so they thought well
seriously fatal plus seriously
contagious it's like what could be
better than happy for disaster right
right and so then you might say well is
crossing Ebola with smallpox
if is seeing whether you can cross Ebola
with smallpox a reasonable scientific
question an appropriate scientific
question and purely from the perspective
of science
yes science is a generic problem-solving
mechanism now you might say well no it's
like it's not something any reasonable
human being should ever engage in but
that's not the same thing as asking
whether or not it's a question within
the reasonable purview of science I mean
the thing about science is that science
was designed to be as value-free of
methodology as possible it's designed
for that and so then people say well why
is there a gap between science and
values it's like well cuz it's built
into the methodology so it looks to me
like you need something that's outside
of science to direct the ethic and it
seems to me that something like the
stories can't come from within science I
don't see how I mean partly because it
diluted the value isn't the story of the
cosmos already
enough to get someone excited enough to
find some sort of value system from the
being born from the Stars and that being
inspiration no not necessarily because
you can just as easily say well you know
here we are in this little dirt ball in
the middle you know on the outer edge of
this galaxy that's rotating going to
rotate pointlessly for the next 250
million years you know a couple of dozen
billion years before the heat death of
the universe it's like that's pretty
dismal accounting of the utility of life
I mean you know what I mean you can take
you sure we're taking you have that
entire you have that entire range of
interpretive possibilities from like
isn't life remarkable and wonderful and
to isn't it bloody pointless if you if
you look at it from the wrong temper I
think I can find that from science
well yeah but you can also find the
reverse so that's the problem I'm not
anti scientific yeah yeah but worse I
don't I don't see a simple way of
solving the problem of of of the ethical
direction of the scientific inquiry I
mean um
you know what what comes to mind maybe
as a waiter
get to that area well one of the things
that I talked about in detail with Sam
Harrison we're gonna talk about this
some more because it's by no means
solved is the relationship between facts
and values and the old idea Humes ideas
you can't derive values from a set of
facts and I think that's sort of right
but I do I kind of think it's more
complicated than Hume that it was but
I'm not exactly sure why because like I
made a case earlier about this emergent
ethic arising out of out of out of
iterated games that kind of looks like a
scientific observation about the origin
of morality at something like that so
it's not like science can't inform your
moral decisions but exactly how that
might come about is by no means a
straightforward issue and a fascinating
well it's also not the case it is also
not self-evident
that science has served a beneficial
function for human beings like it might
be the case it could be the case I mean
look we're pretty comfortable here and
thank God and that's definitely a
consequence of the Scientific Revolution
but but you know highlighted your phone
as a major yeah yeah but one good
hydrogen bomb blowing up over North
America would set us back about 50
thousand years and that could easily
happen if I was a paranoid dictator
that's certainly what I would do and I
don't know you yeah yeah most of you
guys probably know what would happen if
you blow up a hydrogen bomb I think it's
about 150 miles up something like that
one you get an electromagnetic pulse it
takes all the electronics out like all
of them right
one bomb and so like maybe we'll manage
that but it wouldn't and you know maybe
we'll manage that transition to whatever
we're going to do next but I wouldn't
count on it
and so it isn't even necessarily the
case that scientific endeavor is a pro
human life process and what we do with
it is bone that's why you said earlier
that it's important now more than ever
to have these conversations about the
future of humanity and where are we
going how are we going to do this
together so let's let's talk about just
ending it off with mutual exploration I
really thought this was interesting and
the intellectual dark web is a really
good example of this which you are a
main pillar of in my opinion so let's
say that two people are having a
conversation and they're reducing their
points they're maybe keeping it to a
straight binary we see a lot of
political polarization that's occurring
today in the United States politics
finding a lot of the beauty and the
nuance of conversation when you take
complex position and you maybe stay it
quantum estate 'add all these things
tend to drive better conversations and
it seems as though you're leading that
forefront what what what do you see in
that sort of path that we're walking of
figuring out how to have better
conversations
there's a I write about this a fair bit
in 12 rules for life there's a chapter I
think it's chapter 9 I think that's
right
assume that the persons that you're
listening to know something you don't
it's kind of a derivation of some of
some things that I learned from Carl
Rogers who was a great clinician great
20th century clinician his star sort of
rose during the 1960's he was a humanist
um he was a Christian missionary when he
was a kid but he dropped that and he
became a leading light humanistic
psychology and he was really interested
in the preconditions for therapeutic
conversation um and he thought that well
if you were going to engage in the
process of therapy with a client that
the client had to bring to the session
before he or she arrived the willingness
to make things better that would be the
first thing yeah right so that and I've
done therapy that was court-mandated
like I wouldn't recommend that that just
doesn't work very well
you know because you can't force someone
to be better they have to kind of come
already thinking that there's a bunch of
things they don't know and that their
life could be better than it already is
that's a good position to take when
you're engaging in a conversation with
someone it's like look if you already
know enough more power to you man you
know but if you're suffering more than
you think is necessary which is like
highly probable or more than you think
is desirable which basically means if
you're suffering more than you think is
desirable that means that you're way
more ignorant than you need to be right
that's what it means because maybe you
have an illness you don't know how to
cure it yeah maybe you're having a fight
with someone you don't know how get out
of it maybe you're failing at work and
you don't know what to do about it's
like you're ignorant and no wonder
because people are ignorant and so you
might think well unless everything is
just the way you want it to be then you
have something to learn and then you
think well maybe the person you're
talking to no matter how
comfortable you are with their opinions
and how bent out of shape you think they
are maybe even how bent out of shape
they actually are there's always the
possibility that if you actually engaged
in a conversation you asked them
questions and you tried to figure out
what they thought that you'd come away
with one crumb of knowledge more than
you had when you went into the
conversation and like conversations like
that are a lot more interesting I found
in my you know I've probably done twenty
thousand hours of clinical work
something like that and so that's twenty
thousand hours of really really really
really serious conversations and they're
almost always interesting beyond belief
and like I've had clients that's I told
you already that sort of spanned the
entire spectrum from people who were so
impaired cognitively and behaviorally
that while they were utterly
unemployable by any any reasonable
standards to people who were
unbelievably high-functioning and I
found working with all of them if I if
I'm in the zone properly it's
ridiculously fascinating yeah because
people are ridiculously interesting and
so and and everyone has their own
characteristic experience that's
actually unique and so if you have a
real conversation with someone and they
tell you what's unique about their
experience the probability that you can
learn something from that is but it's
certain that you can my my low IQ
clients god they taught me so much it's
just they taught me how difficult things
were first you know because to see
someone struggle with a task that the
typical person can do without even
thinking sheds light on exactly how
amazing it is that that normal people
can do that and how hard it is when when
you were impaired to the point where
those sorts of normal behaviors become
become impossible it's so enlightening
it teaches you a lot about the world and
so I think part of the reason that
YouTube is killing television is partly
because it's technologically
advantageous I mean make no mistake
about it there's nothing that TV can do
that YouTube can't do and there's a
whole bunch of things that YouTube can
do that TV can't so it's obvious which
one's going to win but what's also
interesting about it is that there seems
to be a massive and relatively untapped
market for actual conversation and it's
because conversation is
between people of goodwill we're trying
to tell the truth we're trying to aim it
making things better is unbelievably
valuable I mean at least in principle
that's what we're all doing here right I
mean yeah even though you know you guys
aren't talking um that doesn't mean this
isn't a conversation you know it's first
of all we're trying to pay attention to
you at least enough to see if everyone's
is engaged in the conversation if you're
not engaged in it then it would be
completely pointless right and you would
involve them in your experiment that was
amazing well one of the things I learned
in my clinical practice is that if the
conversation wasn't interesting then I
was doing it wrong
yeah straights just be good then and
that's a really cool thing too I think
that also speaks to this idea of a
universal ethic I've really become
interested I talked about this with Ian
McGilchrist recently I just released
that video today though it was a week
ago on a different site I've barely
become interested in the idea that the
sense of engagement of meaningful
engagement is the deepest of cognitive
instincts I actually think you can make
a very strong neurobiological case for
that and that that if you're engaged in
something what it means is that you're
safe and secure on the one hand
sufficiently safe and secure you're in
your domain of competence which is a
good place to be you know it's like
explored territory so you're with within
the walls where you're safe but you're
also peering over the fence at the same
time right so if you're engaged what it
means is that you're in your domain of
competence but you're operating within
that domain of competence so that you're
expanding your competence at the same
time and so you feel that as
meaningfully engaged meaningfully
engaging and it is and so and I do also
think that that sense of meaningful
engagement is the right antidote to the
suffering that's that's that's part and
parcel of our limited existence it's
like you need an antidote to the fact
that life is suffering and the the
experience of meaningful engagement I
think is that antidote and I also think
that the experience of meaningful
engagement is a marker that you're where
you should be doing what you should be
at the right time yeah I think it's the
deepest of cognitive incidence and so
that's really cool man if that was true
I think it's actually true so for me
something if that was true man
but I think it is so when we see if it
works in that state of flow you lose a
sense of time yeah well you lose
yourself consciousness too as well so
and that's something that's worth
thinking but I would also consider that
a primary religious experience it's
something like that yeah you know you're
talking about science and religion
earlier and like there's a bunch of
questions that we need to address pretty
seriously about that too because the the
scientific the kind of atheist types you
know they're very down on the idea of
religion but that's a very bad idea
because religion is a human universal
right and the religious experience
people have religious experiences it's
like minimum we need an explanation for
that plus you can induce them which is
also you know you care you can't just
write that off like you can induce
religious experiences I can come up with
that virtual as well right yeah with
religious spiritual so but it's not it's
not just conceptual like you know you
can say horses realm it's deeply
experiential it has to be yeah Jordan
are we in a computer simulation if we
are it's within a computer that we don't
understand I look I think questions like
that are strange because welcome to
simulation well it's like it's it's like
asking whether you can reduce
consciousness to material to to its
material substrate and the answer that
is yes but by the time we reduce
consciousness to its material substrate
our understanding of what that material
substrate is will have transformed so
dramatically that it won't look very
much like the material substrate that we
presume now and so if we're in a
simulation then it's within the confines
of a mechanism that we can't easily
assimilate to our own computational
devices so it's it's it and then of
course the other problem with question
like that is well we've already defined
this as reality and so is reality a
simulation it's well know by definition
it's not it's you might say well the
simulation can get so real that you
can't distinguish it from reality but
you start
almost all questions of the forum is a
be devolve down to it depends on how you
define a and B because the problem with
questions like that is a decontextualize
as the terms right it's like well what
do you mean by reality what do you mean
by simulation well if you mean the same
thing by both of them then they're the
same thing if you mean different things
by both of them then they're different
things and so well but I'm serious if
you have serious about that you know
well most of the time you can't pull
single terms out of a conversational
stream and assume that the term has a
bounded definition that's self-evident
using only that term because when we
converse it's like well you utter a
stream of words it's like well what are
the words mean well it depends on where
they are in the phrase it depends on
where they are in the sentence it
depends on where the sentence is located
in the paragraph it depends on the
context within which the paragraph is
uttered and you you triangulate all of
that simultaneously to extract out the
meaning of the word and then if you take
a word out like it's a thing and another
word out like it's a thing and you say
are these two things the same you're
acting as if those words can be
decontextualized and they have absolute
meaning and in their decontextualize
state and they don't so so so usually
those questions I would say in some
sense are philosophically are
philosophically untenable so so well
that's the answer that's
[Applause]
for those of you that haven't done a
self authoring or understand myself
they're incredible programs there's a
20% off code it's San Fran so give that
a go thanks Jordan appreciate you I
appreciate you coming out here and San
Francisco Bay Area really enjoyed having
you we hope to have you again soon thank
you
Jordan thank you everyone that was very
much fun yep
[Music]
it's good
feet
you